hello everyone and welcome to today's
ionix webinar
it's a pleasure for
all of us to see you all today here
we will be waiting for a few more
minutes so that everybody can join in
and then we will begin with today's
exciting
webinar on
data science and computational biology
by dr
gupta from empty university noida
so hold on tight to your seats
we are going to begin in a few more
minutes
so we are waiting for
everyone to join in we will start in
more five minutes or so
meanwhile
while we wait for
the webinar to begin it would be great
to get to know all of you
where are you from
what's your
interests
what are you studying so please feel
free to put it down in the chat section
it would make the session even more
interactive and meaningful
to be able to know you well
and
very soon we will be beginning with
today's exciting session
uh
like
b
all right hello everyone and
good evening good morning
to everyone who are joining us from
different parts of the world
it's my pleasure again to
welcome you all to yet another exciting
session of cyanx
the student club
made for you guys bioinformatics
enthusiasts from all across the world
i welcome you all
for
again for another exciting session today
but before we begin let's introduce the
club to all of you
today i will be your host my name is
subrajet
and i am the president of the thyonic
student club
and
the vice president of this club is miss
ruth
what is psyomix well psyonix is a
community it's a family of more than 1
000 students from
more than 20 experts who assist and
guide us in various aspects of
computational biology and bioinformatics
through their educational programs and
training
and we are also very proud of 30 plus
rich alumni network who have been a part
of our community for a long long time
and now they are making their mark in
the world outside with their vast
knowledge and expertise
psionics as i mentioned is a student
club which is supported by pine biotech
and omix logic the goal and the vision
of this club is to clear the concepts of
bioinformatics to help the students gain
useful insights on how to use various
bioinformatics tools that are rapidly
growing in this era
also to learn how to apply these
concepts in day-to-day life science
research
we also have brainstorming sessions
where we discuss various up-and-coming
research and tools
and to find out the ways to best use
them
we also discuss and have sessions on
coding exercises where we learn to use
python r and other coding languages
which we can use for bioinformatics
analysis
and the overall goal is to bring
together like-minded people who are
interested in the various niches of
biological data science such as
infectious diseases microbiome and
metagenomics neuroscience plant science
physician oncology and even
the modern field of space omnics and
astrobiology
now as i said let me introduce you to
the concept of our mix logic what it is
and what is its goal and purpose
well omixlogic programs that they have
developed is used to provide training to
students and researchers all across the
globe to enable them to complete their
independent research project guided by
mentor and peer examples
apart from education and training omix
logic also focuses on developing a
growing community
with the shared passion for data-driven
research
which can be also applied to citizen
science projects
and by doing this omics logic makes
students able to compete with the world
and to assist clinicians and faculties
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using the latest
technologies in life and data science
this month at sciomix we are observing
the data science month where we will be
talking and brainstorming about the
various applications of data science
technologies tools and techniques in
bioinformatics and biological research
in this era it is needless to say that
the amount of data that is generated is
massive
these data nowadays can be well seen
that to be generated at a very fast rate
from hospitals and other clinical
organizations the kobit 19 pandemic
itself showed us the enormous amount of
data that can be generated from one
particular pandemic or one particular
event
with the growing number of data it
becomes very very useful to be able to
analyze and to extract meaningful
information from this data
and that is what we call as data science
this is a very popular term in today's
world which needs no explanation it is
also one of the highest grossing term in
the job market section nowadays
but what does data science consist of
data science consists of obviously the
data that is generated the various
statistical methods that are established
and the application in various
specialization domains which together
brings to life the term data science
and this particular science can be
applied in biological
application fields which then takes the
form of bioinformatics where
if you want to look at the various
aspects it could contain informatics
statistics and the biological concepts
and finally the application of various
analytical methods and even machine
learning into the omics technologies
which define the features of
an organism of a living being
now when we talk about data what sort of
data are we talking about from a
biologist's perspective well data can be
generated from various techniques such
as a microscope can generate data and
also next generation sequencing can give
rise to various
genomic data now these data sets can be
then
filtered and structured giving rise to
some insights which can be further
subjected to various tools and
algorithms which further can analyze
them classify them and then give rise to
meaningful data which we can understand
as a biologist these steps of data
handling can be classified into three
categories namely the unstructured data
that are very commonly available in
today's world semi-unstructured data and
structured data and all of these sorts
of data are useful from a bioinformatics
bioinformaticial point of view
now where can we find this sort of data
well this sort of data is
hugely available publicly available from
a number of repositories such as the
national center for biotechnology
information ncbi gene expression omnibus
which stores transfer atomic data ncbi
virus where all the data sets about
viruses including kovid 19 can be found
and the list goes on and on with the
rapid increase in the generation of data
sets in today's world it becomes more
and more
compelling for us that is the data
scientists and bioinformaticians to
analyze them and to extract meaning from
those data sets we often end up using
various machine learning and other
statistical tools which ultimately help
us
answer that particular question that
particular biological meaning that we
are looking for from these data sets
and what can we do with these
information that we find out well
our life applications research
and help solve a
problem which is a disease such as this
one
the covid19 pandemic
well
i hope this introduction
makes you much more interested and
excited about this exciting domain of
life science research which is up and
coming that is data science in
bioinformatics and today we are
privileged to have an expert who will be
sharing many more insights about this
exciting field
and it's my pleasure to welcome today dr
abhishek singh gupta
from who is an
assistant professor from the center for
computational biology and bioinformatics
at amnesty institute of biotechnology
i'm at university with the pradesh dr
san gupta is a self-motivated
enthusiastic computational biologist and
teacher who seeks excellence in
bioinformatics and systems biology
research and education
he earned his master's degree in
bioinformatics from ntu's school of
science and technology in 2007 and his
phd in bioinformatics from amity
university in 2015.
he is presently working at amity
university and his research interests
include biological network construction
and integration boolean modelling
constraint based modeling multiomics
integration using machine learning and
data-driven hypothesis formulation he
and his team primarily
employ computational tools to examine
metabolic and gene regulatory disease
networks as well as to better understand
disease progression and molecular
processes uncover new pharmaceutical
targets and suggest drug repurposing
options so it's my immense pleasure
today to welcome dr saint gupta who will
be talking about network construction
and inference as an elegant approach to
understand disease pathogenesis
thank you so much dr sengupta for
joining us today
and i hope that you are doing great
yes thank you thank you mr garuwa
thank you for this kind uh introduction
and thank you for inviting me
uh
to
this interesting session that is uh
by pine biotech
and we have a great uh collaboration
with fine biotech and we have been doing
really our collaboration is have been
doing really great
and uh
on that note uh i am glad to be a part
of this session and uh
uh
thank you everyone uh
for being present here
and uh
good evening and good morning to
different parts of the world
participants from different parts of the
world
and uh
about me i'm dr abhishek sengupta and
i'll be talking about today
yeah i can can i share my slide first
yeah sure
so uh
as uh uh mr barwa has uh given an
introduction about myself so i will be
i miss uh i'm a bioinformatician and
turn into a systems biologist and also
do lots of work in bioinformatics
research and as well as specifically to
systems biology
so my topic of
presentation today am i audible is my
voice clear to everyone
yes daughters
absolutely clear thank you
uh so uh the topic of my prayer of my
talk today is network construction and
inference
as an elegant approach to understand
disease pathogenesis
and so uh to begin with uh first of all
i uh wanted to uh define uh or explain
uh what do we understand by systems
biology because uh till you understand
systems biology this is the subject this
is a broader umbrella under which we
study uh about networks
as uh mr barua has given you an
introduction about data and the
data from
biological sciences and how uh those
data can be uh used for getting
meaningful insights from those data and
those certain predictions etc so that is
uh one aspect
of
of data of data science in our big data
in biology today where we use aiml uh
techniques and the other aspect other
end is where other application is rather
where we use systems biology modeling
and simulations or network analysis or
network uh studies uh uh to get
inferences so so the objective is more
or less same in both the cases where uh
in the in the previous one we uh
we uh get uh insights and those
predictions using aiml methods here we
use various mathematical
uh and theoretical uh
modeling strategies our network network
or topological analysis
for in systems biology to get those
insights right so there are two ends uh
there are two
ways by which you can dig out
meaning or from those big data in
biology
so that you as you all know there is a
huge uh
data explosion everywhere uh in
biological uh sciences or biomedical
sciences uh and uh those data has are
generated by using high throughput
techniques um
various high throughput techniques like
for example ngs
then
mass spectrometry
etc then
so this data needs to get some meaning
right so otherwise um we if we don't get
uh
any conclusion or inference from those
data
analysis is of no use uh so that's the
main person main aim so systems biology
is one such area uh though it is not a
very
uh new field of science um uh it has uh
it has been studied uh like uh it has
been studying in um
this has been you uh most researchers
have been using these systems biology
approaches uh from the very beginning
itself uh since uh biology has been
started studying so initially it used to
be called as uh
theoretical or mathematical uh biology
now uh with the with the data now with
the all those omics uh data that we have
or other other proteomics or
metabolomics data that we have they had
this whole systems biology has taken a
new new uh face right uh so that's how
systems biology uh is involved these
days in every university so you go
abroad in your universities they have a
systems biology uh department or systems
biology research groups
right so
uh
let's start with some basics uh the with
what what we understand for the
beginners who has never heard who has
never uh come across this uh
uh this field of science that systems by
what is systems biology systems biology
uh is the is what we um when we study
the components of a of any biological
system
um and their interactions and how those
interactions uh actually give rise to uh
to certain functions and behavior of
that system so those behaviors are
coherent behavior so they keep on
interacting among themselves and give
rise to those behaviors of a system
right those behaviors are um exactly
exactly you can say a bird's eye view
of the whole system or or its function
right or it could be in the form of
certain phenotype or physiological role
of that of that system so this
definition is given by near friedman he
is a
he is a computational scientist and also
a computational biologist um who who is
who's from uh university of hebrew in
jerusalem
right and he has been he works in the
area of uh of systems biology and also
uh machine learning approaches to study
gene regulation so he has given this uh
he has coined his
definitions though there are various
definitions you if you google uh
the term systems biology you'll get many
other definitions anyways uh so the
behavior of a system depends on um on
two things right one is the properties
of the uh
uh the components of this is uh
properties of the components of the
system and the interactions between
those components components
so in molecular biology uh what we have
seen so far uh the whole approach is a
more of a reductionist approach and the
paradigm is shifting from that
reductionist approach to the
systems approach uh where we um haven't
have a heaven uh have a idea of
integrative
integrative biology or integrative
approach or specific interactions of
components in the biological systems are
studied like cells tissues organs
ecological web so there are various
hierarchies at which it can be studied
starting from the molecular or atomic
level uh
that is the cells tissues organs until
the ecological level so systems biology
can be studied at various levels right
so uh systems biology is a very uh
multi-disciplinary field of science so
you all are aware of classical
bioinformatics which is always also
called as a multi dc which is always
been defined as a multi-disciplinary
field of science similar resistance
systems biology is a very advanced uh
field or
applicative field of bioinformatics
so that definitely
it is also a multi-disciplinary
field of science right so
sorry so it is a multi-disciplinary uh
field of
science
fine so uh
we have um
we you can see in this slide that it is
it has biology
it has engineering sciences
bioinformatics uh physics computer
science mathematics all are integrated
together so biology definitely because
uh this is what is the basis here right
we are not anyway studying an electrical
system or electronic system or or
any
any transport system right so we are
studying here biological system so
though the concepts are also been
the same concepts are also being used in
uh studying um studying other
non-biological systems also right or
models also but uh here
we uh the the basic problem is uh
problem or hypothesis or experiments are
definitely biological in nature so why
engineering science uh why engineering
science is a part of uh because uh the
like if you if you see classical
bioinformatics we don't see engineering
science concepts here but in systems
biology we see this uh engineering
science concepts here because we use uh
the concepts of networks we use the
concepts of control theory we use the
concepts of uh
system sciences uh even the uh systems
based uh systems based modeling and
simulation uh
simulation concepts have come from come
from the engineering sciences because
you must have heard that um
engineers design
cars design aeroplanes design uh
different electronic items uh even even
this
social networking sites like social like
they are also designed uh on the basis
of these network concepts right so so uh
so so all these concepts have come from
the engineering science concepts and now
through systems biology it has been used
in uh
by uh in uh biology right so and the uh
one of the
major or uh major
aspect in systems biology is networks uh
is uh
studying biology using networks right so
that is my main motto here to
tell you how networks can be used to
study
biological problems or to understand
biological problems then bioinformatics
because we use various databases various
uh as as uh mr bharava has mentioned the
the different uh resources like um
like ncbi uniprot ensemble so all these
are various uh bioinformatics resources
right basic bioinformatic resources so
all those are also been used in systems
biology uh in some
way or the other
then we have uh computer science we use
various programming environments to do
modeling and simulation or to create
more to create networks or network
models so we use
we use standard we used uh gui based uh
tools and also we use uh programming
based uh tools and apps uh
right uh using uh using python uh
packages using our
libraries or
using matlab toolboxes right so that's
how computer science is a part of it as
well then physics definitely physics and
biology are in sim are inseparable field
of sciences so
dynamics uh kinetics motions so all
these all these are uh physical aspects
that uh that are important part of
biology which are touched upon in
systems biology which are
being used uh to model um in systems
biology then mathematics definitely no
when we create predictive models in
systems biology
we use uh
different mathematical approaches like
using uh ordinary differential equations
using partial uh differential equations
odepd's
then
then various probability based
approaches uh then
then stor stoichiometries uh matrices
stoichiometries are anyways matrices so
matrices kinetic equations so all these
are all these are mathematical problems
and they are being used here to uh to uh
solve problems in systems biology so i
hope you understood what uh what
is uh why systems biology is basically a
multi-disciplinary field of science now
next is uh
that in the important features of
systems biology so it has been um
responsible for some of the most
important developments in the science of
human uh
health and environmental uh
sustainability so it is a holistic
approach to decipher bring the
complexity of biological
systems that starts um that starts from
the understanding that the networks that
form the whole of living organisms are
more than the sum of their parts right
so
it is collaborative so it is basically a
holistic approach right so we don't uh
study on the basis of one gene two genes
or three genes proteins one protein two
proteins no we use hundreds of genes
hundreds of proteins or probably the
whole system uh however uh what is the
however the uh
number of genes could be as many as uh
like
one thousand ten thousand uh
in number or 30 000 in number so uh
their sizes are in terabytes anyways uh
so those are huge system huge number of
data in in um that need that are uh
that are uh
that are part of those systems so uh
studying them together is a holistic
approach so systems biology is a
holistic approach it is collaborative in
nature so i have already mentioned
i have already explained why it is
collaborative in nature uh integrating
various uh field basic field of sciences
and then it is
its ability to design
its predictive multiscale models though
you can you can design it at the
molecular level atomic level then at the
tissue level cellular level organ level
organism levels we talk about various
organism level models where for example
the whole set a whole organism
based metabolic models or genome scale
metabolic models of human genome scale
metabolic models of e coli saccharomyces
dairy derivative so
so in short we call them as gems so that
is at the organism level even at the um
at the population level the various
epidemiological models like for example
the best example the sir models mo sir
model is one of the examples right uh so
that can be that you know that also
comes under the basic area of uh basic
umbrella or the uh overall umbrella of
systems biology right um so uh
so that's how it is uh multiscaler in
nature it enables our scientists to
discover new biomarkers for diseases uh
stratify patients uh based on unique
genetic profiles and target
identification for various uh
for drug designing purpose and other
treatments systems biology ultimately
creates the potential for entirely
new kinds of exploration and drives
constant innovation um innovation in
biology based technology and computation
right so these are some of the important
features of systems biology fine now
systems biology workflow how it it
actually um
how if but
a
particular research is taking place
using such this workflows right so uh
just one second
so you can see here the uh systems
biology workflow
so this picture uh depicts the general
process of systems biology you can or
you can say the workflow of systems
biology it is an iterative process so
this is in cycle so it is an iterative
process
uh which begins with collecting and
integrating multiplex data so we start
with multi omics data here from high
throughput experiments like uh how you
know about uh big data in ah or large
high throughput data in um in in biology
or uh or biological sciences or
biomedical sciences right so those data
uh can be uh integrated uh uh the or
multi-omics uh uh or those multi omics
data can be integrated from high
throughput experiments uh it moves on to
design and build a model so we may build
a model here uh this is called as model
building right uh so it has some
resemblance with the aiml based uh
approaches but here the uh uh
the approaches the various modeling
formalisms or techniques are little uh
are not little is absolutely different
uh from uh from the algorithms are
different right so this is little
different from um from uh how we study
um
uh
the it uh from a from a data scientist
perspective data scientist perspective
so this is an engineering perspective of
our engineers perspective of uh of uh
studying uh or doing modeling or
simulations in system using systems
biology right so model building here uh
we do model building uh using uh various
bioinformatics and mathematical
approaches using computational and
simulation tools one can proceed to
analyze and interpret the data so this
is model analysis and interpretation so
from analysis and interpretation we come
up come out with hypothesis generation
then hypothesis uh testing so we do the
testing of the hypothesis and then so
see here modular a modeling and then
experimentation goes hand in hand so
it's not only solely um solely
computational in nature but we need
experimental data to uh validate it at
every steps right so it starts with
experimental data but in between um
in between there are various uh sections
where we also use experimental data to
keep on validating it so they so a
modeler and a or a systems biology star
and an experimental biologist work hand
in hand to uh come up with a now with
the model
that represents the real world system
accurately right so what is the what is
the basic aim of modeling to
make some make a replica or to make a
to mimic the real world system so that
we can solve and we can do various
predictions we can solve various uh we
can understand various complex problems
uh through those models right so that is
the basic workflow of a systems biology
experiment
uh so next are key properties of
biological systems or models like uh
yes so every biological uh
systems or sorry every every biological
systems or models uh have certain
properties now these properties are uh
all uh quantifiable properties they are
not just english words
that you are seeing here that
irreducibility emerges complexity
modularity so they all are com
quantifiable
properties and quantifiable
aspects of uh of of any any any
biological system of any biological
system so when it's when i talk about
biological systems or just for your uh
for your understanding you can think
about any biological system starting
from a cell to protein complexes to cell
membrane then disease pathogenesis uh
to
for example cell cycle
transcription translation processes
right uh this is like no complex
diseases like neurodegenerative diseases
autoimmune disorders so anything can be
considered as a system but every system
has certain properties right which i'm
which i wanted to show you here in this
slide uh where
irreducibility uh is the first property
where we may undoubtedly gain
significant insight into each of the
components of the system by studying
them individually but we need to under
study the system as a whole in order to
gain a holistic
perspective of what these components do
when they are all put together in an
appropriate
manner so that's what is irreducibility
of a system for example cellular
respiration right so you can give the
example of a cellular respiration then
emergence
emergence is quite similar to
irreducibility but
it has a different uh it is a different
property where systems are composed of
different of individual elements or
parts that interact in various ways in
general the behavior of a system is
different quite different from merely
the sum of the functions of its various
parts this reinforces the need to
develop uh methods to study biological
systems at the systems level rather than
at the um at the level of individual
components right so
next is complexity so complexity is
definitely a very important property of
biological systems so most of the
biological systems are very very complex
in nature so we are aim as a systems
biologist to target this complexity to
understand those complexity of
biological systems in certain quantities
or in certain quantifiable manner and
for example health and disease so health
and disease is uh one of the best
example of a complex system for example
cancer for example diabetes so they are
very complex disorders right uh
and and uh and making a blueprint
blueprint of them that is making a model
of them is uh is again a very havoc task
and that's what we do in systems biology
this cannot be predicted simply by
analyzing the individual ligands or
proteins that comprise these cells a
more
complete picture of their context would
be necessary to achieve it
biological systems are needless to say
that
they are extraordinarily complex as i
said and which is evident in individual
prokaryotic cells
not only in prokaryotic cells but also
in various multicellular organ uh
organisms right so uh so for example uh
the insulin um insulin production uh the
uh um for
insulin production uh in diabetes or or
or how insulin production regulates uh
regulates the blood glucose level in a
diabetic patient so or probably how
diabetes is related to obesity
or how diabetes is related to
cardiovascular diseases so all these are
complex aspects and
that defines the complexity of a
biological system next is modularity so
what is modularity bacterial systems may
be viewed so modularity our
modules constitute semi-autonomous
entities right so every um
it's not that a
a
particular biological process takes
place in in a uniform or a homogeneous
system they have heterogeneity
in the system uh which are called as
different modules or different clusters
um that uh work together uh to run uh
that system or to for the functioning of
that system so whenever i say system
that means biological system right so uh
so that's modularity is very important
and it can also be uh it can also be
mathematically expressed so all these
properties can be mathematically
expressed
or has been already mathematically
expressed or defined right so
then robustness and fragility so
robustness and fragility
is again a very uh important uh property
so there are so much fluctuations um
that happen inside a cell
i'm just giving an example as cell as a
system
so
those perturbations or those
fluctuations that comes from the that
are inter intracellular and
extracellular fluctuations um in a in a
cell so that can be um
in spite of those fluctuations the
system um remains steady or remains um
or maintains its
excuse me and maintains its uh
homeostasis uh so that is called as
robustness right and sensitivity and
fragility is that with the
simplest changes in
uh changes in uh in the
concentrations of certain uh certain
metabolites or
or one point mutation or
or probably uh one small structural
change in an enzyme can cause a huge
difference in this whole system right
that can cause that cause a disease
excuse me
so that's what is robustness and
fragility and robustness and fragility
is one of the another important aspect
then there is evolvability also uh
evolvability of systems so that is
another property of biological systems
now networks uh let's come to our uh
main topic that is network so systems
biology is huge uh right now there are
many aspects of many applications of
systems biology um but uh
the one uh so systems biology has
modeling uh and simulation aspects also
but modeling and simulation of the whole
biological system not not just what what
you have studied probably in uh in drug
designing where we do molecular modeling
and drug designing this is not molecular
modeling this is this is whole cell
modeling this is whole system modeling
right we are modeling the whole system
we are not taking one module or two one
more one proteins or two proteins
probably and model them into uh so what
that is a different field of uh
bioinformatics all together that is drug
designing
and what that is called as cad that is
computer-aided drug designing right etc
now here we are uh we are all uh we are
all um
trying to understand the uh the whole
system at a time right now
the one of the most important and uh one
of the most uh preliminary study
that we do uh in understanding the whole
system is through networks right so
networks are uh important aspect of
studying
a biological system right uh so uh what
are networks right
what if someone asks you what are
networks a network of complex systems
can be mapped onto a graph in various
ways so networks are also called as
graphs right so they have all come from
the concept of engineering concept that
is graph theory right so we have so
networks are basically graphs in various
ways it it is possible to analyze all
paths between two nodes uh now
now every graph or
network can be defined as a set of nodes
or vertices and edges so that is nodes
and edges and edges describe a
relationship between the nodes uh so you
can see here uh
how betw how uh these
nodes or the number of paths from a node
outside and the number of parts
terminating at a node are defined so
here you can see in the picture or the
diagram uh that's uh below this uh
that's
at the bottom of this slide is here we
can see how nodes can be connected to
each other the figure on the right shows
um how a a affects how a uh affects c
and uh d also uh d but it itself uh but
it itself affected by b and d right uh
while b also uh affects d uh and c
has no connection with b or d again uh
genes cells meta again abcd can be
what are these abcde right now these
abcd are basically the genes proteins
metabolites in a network right so i have
just simplified it or
generalized it into abc here
just for your understanding
now uh
now uh
we have seen here about uh network uh uh
like no water networks networks or nodes
and networks are basically
representation using nodes and edges now
we have various parameters by which
those networks can be or network
topology can be uh parameterized or can
be weighed right so if somebody says
that how good is your network right you
need to quantity you need to tell that
person that your network is uh good on
certain parameters on the basis of
certain parameters or on the basis of
certain values right so you give those
those
figures or those
numbers uh that shows that your network
is actually quite appropriate and uh it
has meaning and you can and you can draw
inferences from it right network biology
so this this this particular topic is
called as network biology you must have
heard somewhere about this subject
called as network biology so this comes
under systems biology right where we
study uh system in the form of networks
so that is called as network biology
this is this is part of systems
biologist network biology and systems
biology are not same systems biology is
huge there are many many aspects of
systems biology we have systems
immunology we have systems microbiology
we have systems uh
systems uh biochemistry we have uh right
so there are systems biology can be
applied to uh any biological field of
sciences but uh the network biology is
more or less concentra even in systems
biologically study uh models predictive
models right we do predictions uh using
models and making a model is not an easy
task right so
so networks are uh just network
represents and it's quite interesting to
get uh
get inferences from or get
insights through these networks so
network biology provides a quantifiable
uh description of networks there are
several network measures that enable the
comparison and uh and and
characterization of uh complex uh
networks now first one is connectivity
or degree we call how how well they are
connected how how well and it's not just
connecting connecting the dots it it's
uh every connection and every um every
dots uh how they are how they are placed
in the network has a meaning it's not
just connecting the dots you think that
network biology is just going to the
string database or epic database or
probably going to cytoscape and join
those dots it's nothing it's not not as
simple as that there are various deeper
in aspects of of networks uh where we
understand networks where we infer from
networks about various uh various uh
understanding of the of those biological
processes right connectivity first is
connectivity now what is connectivity so
here k
represents connectivity is represented
by k or degrees the connect degree of
connectivity is represented by k
so their k represents the number of uh
links the node has to other nodes in the
network for example uh for directed net
so we have two types like directed and
undirected networks so for directed
networks k has two components k in and k
out there are various arrows that are
going out and there are various arrows
which are coming in so everything has a
meaning so they are not uh like no uh
not just uh web web or for uh
complicated pictures uh but uh they have
meaning uh inside them uh or encrypted
in them uh in networks so the in degree
so this gain is in degree and k out is
out degree num uh right so they can be
um
they can be uh
they can be quantified or they can be uh
parameterized uh by using uh softwares
like cytoscape you cytoscape has various
features by which you can uh measure
this measure these parameters right the
degree distribution um degree
distribution is represented by pk is
obtained by counting the number of nodes
uh with k like one two links and uh one
comma two number of links one and
dividing by the number of nodes uh to
distinguish between the various network
topologies then clustering coefficient
is another um another important
parameter of uh studying the um
the quality of a network where the
average clustering coefficient
characterizes the overall tendency of
nodes to form uh clusters of groups
which is represented by ck ck is defined
as the average average clustering uh
clustering
clustering coefficients for all nodes
with k links
so
it is also called as uh we have clicks
diagnose certain clicks or we have
certain hubs so they have different
meanings in network biological clicks
hubs uh
modules uh or sub graphs so they have
different meanings right um so
characteristics of path length so when
we uh when when when we have two nodes
there is a path between those two nodes
it measures the typical uh separation
between two vertices in the network uh
intuitively it uh represents the
network's overall navigability right now
how the network is actually navigating
from one node to the other node so the
whole navigability can um can be
represented by the path lengths then we
have network diameters there are huge
number of parameters we have a book
totally a book by barabasi uh
bushnan barabasi and bushna
albert barabasi and bushnan
where he has explained so many type of
properties of our network parameters and
every parameter gives you different
meanings different inferences which you
cannot solve at the
molecular level or at the singular level
we you can only solve it at the system
level when you have everything in front
of you all the genes all the proteins
all the metabolites in front of you and
you can uh infer from them right from
their connectivities so
so that's all about uh network diameter
so there is a network diameter as well
uh where the network diameter is the
greatest distance between two nodes in
the network fine
now uh
let's move ahead so we have on the basis
of uh these nodes and edges and the
parameters we have various types of
biological networks we have different
types of biological networks now
biological networks uh could be many
types right uh networks have no limit
now you can you can make disease
networks you can make disease gene
networks you can make drug
g net
drug gene protein networks you can make
uh
so there are various type of bipartite
networks or graphs uh that you can make
so for better understanding you should
always start with understanding the
intracellular networks like the
intracellular networks are more uh
more uh
easier to start with uh so for example
metabolic networks we have gene
regulatory network signal transduction
or cell signaling networks protein
protein interaction networks right etc
so these are uh these are uh the
intracellular networks these are also
intracellular networks but they don't
come under any particular category
so they are very specific like for
example immune network or immunological
networks depending on all the immune
immunological aspects you can make
networks then there are drug target
interaction networks or dtis we call
them as dtis and this particular field
is called as network medicine these days
these days there is a
field of science called as network
medicine or
network pharmacology so all these comes
all these counts the
drug target interaction networks fine um
right so next
is
now
whenever we make a network uh in any
platform in uh in any tool or in any uh
in any uh platform like for example in
cytoscape or in cell designer you make a
network right or uh
right so those networks are represented
in certain formats right so there are
file formats for networks also or models
also systems biology models also
networks and models are different things
right
models are predictive in nature networks
are not predictive in nature they cannot
predict anything they only give you
inferences and they only give you
insights about the various interactions
right so systems biology have various
uh so various formats uh like for one of
like the one of the format that
one of the very widely used format is
called as sbml format that is systems
biology markup language it's an xml
based format and
that is extensible markup language based
format and uh
a representation format uh it is a
representation format for communicating
and storing computational models of
biological process even the networks can
also be represented in spml format then
they are free and open standards with
widespread software support they can
represent many different classes of
biological phenomena including metabolic
networks cell signaling so all those
interested types of networks can be
represented using sbml file format now
next is another type of file format is
there which is
quite widely used for
cell based networks like whole cell
networks so we can make global networks
of the whole cell the whole cell where
the various intracellular
networks are integrated among themselves
like the cell signaling the
metabolic networks uh cell signaling
networks gene regulatory networks all
are integrated among themselves and make
the uh whole setup of the cell network
so
it is represented in another format
called as cell ml format which is again
in
again an xml based uh format and uh
and it has uh it describe also describes
mathematical models similar it is
similar to html format but it provides
greater scope of the model modularity
and reusability and it is not specific
to descriptors of biochemistry
any anyone can submit reviews update
models and receive feedbacks and help
from the community of cell ml a slml
discussion um so
several other formats are also available
other than cell ml like mathml is there
then biopacks format is there so there
are different other types of formats by
which systems biology or network biology
based uh
models and networks can be represented
and used in different softwares uh for
various analysis and for various uh
inference
inferences or insights
getting inferences and insights now
these are systems biology databases uh
that we use quite uh
frequently quite widely first one is
database it is a collection of
database with genomes biological
pathways so it is not a pathway database
it's a very comprehensive database this
get database it has it has keg genes
scat proteins keg
drugs right now so it has it is a very
comprehensive database like ncbi so cake
is not it is a myth that cake is
considered as only a pathway database
not it is not correct keg also has
various uh informations or various
annotations of various genes proteins uh
like single molecules also that is
single biomolecules also fine so then we
have bio models biomodels is especially
a
a free and open source repository for
storing exchanging and retrieving
quantitative models so it is the only
one of the one of the sole uh database
which contains uh biomodels we have um
during my phd i created a
uh created a model uh of
a model that that depicts the um depicts
the energy pool where we i have actually
integrated all the anabolic and
catabolic uh pathways in human um right
and uh made a model
for various predictions uh you uh under
different conditions like
like disease conditions healthy
conditions
fasting condition diabetic condition
different metabolic disorder conditions
so i have tested my model and it has
given exactly same results as as in the
experiment so my model has been
submitted and accepted by biomodels it
is available if any one of you wanted to
use it
in case you are interested in that area
definitely uh you can use it
right so
next is big big database big databases
big database so big databases
is
is the
database for uh
for biochemistry genes and genomes uh so
it contains uh various genome scale
models mostly the models that are being
created by constraint based modeling uh
constraint based modeling and kinetic
modeling
so those models mostly constraint based
modeling
where we generate genome scale or genome
genomics based uh metabolic models uh
model reconstructions or genome-based
model reconstructions uh can be found in
big database it has it covers uh the
gems we call them as gems that is genome
scale metabolic models you call also
call them as gsms that is genome scale
metabolic models uh you get
uh you get more than uh like you know uh
more than 50 more 50 models that are
present for various trains or various
organisms and also human also the whole
gem of human has been is is uh you'll
you can find in big database
right then we have uh react home
database which is a free online database
for biological pathways rectum is also
by uh so okay biomodels is biomodels is
a database for uh by embl ebi similarly
bio psych is also uh sorry reactom is
also a database by uh by embl ebi uh in
collaboration with some other uh
organizations in europe and uh reactant
database is quite opposite to uh buyer
models it has only the pathway
information but it is very very
attractive
uh reactant database so you get
you get informations like google maps
like you keep on uh you you take a
pathway you you get you take a network
you you keep on scrolling it and
you can keep on zooming it out and you
keep on entering into the intricacies of
that of that network uh into the
metabolites into the various genes that
it encodes for so it's very interesting
to explore react from database then we
have biocide database metasite database
then for for protein protein
interactions um we have epid database
that is agile protein interaction data
analyzer
so
it is uh mostly you must have heard
about string database so string is not
the only database that you can use for
protein protein interactions you also
can use epic database app it is also uh
quite a useful database as string
probably you may not find something in
string you can search it in epit
database also right so they are used uh
they both are used for uh protein
protein interactions
now we have various tools here
which are quite widely used if you are
not comfortable with programming
languages uh you can use these gui based
tools like they are they are they are
used quite uh
quite uh
widely
and they are very authenticated you can
publish papers by doing some good work
using cell designer copaci
uh or cytoscape you are aware of
cytoscape i think so and
you can make models in cell designer you
can
do simulations modeling and simulations
in copac
and uh
definitely you know about cytoscape for
visualization of complex networks and
integrating the various uh gene
expression or various expression data or
high throughput data with those type of
uh with any type of attribute data right
so they are all open source uh databases
other than that that you can use the
various toolboxes in matlab you can use
various packages in
various packages in
in
python you can use with systems based
systems biology or network biology based
path
model making
packages are there then you can use in
our programming language also various uh
various libraries and packages
find next
we have these types of systems biology
networks and models we have four major
types of networks models that can be
built based on the research needs and
the
the data in hand and the state of a
system the state of the system is a
snapshot of the system at a given time
that contains uh that contains enough
information to predict the behavior of
the system for all future times so we
have these four uh types uh
deterministic uh that the future state
of the process may be determined by the
current state which uses the ordinary
differential equation based or pde-based
methods stochastic which uh future state
cannot be determined only a probability
can be predicted so where there are
random variables too many random
variables that can be uh done in uh done
using stochastic methods we have
continuous
methods that is called as the the values
of the states are continuous where the
values of the states different states of
the uh of the components are continuous
then we have discrete uh the values of
the states are discrete that is not
continuous where we use this boolean
boolean modeling or uh boolean modeling
methods right
or logic based modeling methods
now network uh model uh network uh
model development and construction so
this is the whole process first of all
formulation uh of the problem
formulation of the problem definitely so
this you just uh
understand this process
this is like a
flow chart or you can say um these steps
formulation of the problem first of all
you need to ask the question that you
are
you wanted to
define you wanted to work on whether you
wanted to identify biomarkers whether
you are going for drug target
identification you are going for
uh optimizing certain metabolites in
biomed by metabolic engineering for
which are used for uh various uh various
product uh
bioproduct formation uh
optimization so these are various
problems that you are so you need to
first identify your problem then
verification uh of the available
information so how much information is
available for your support as a
supporting data for you then selection
of the model structure uh determine the
general type of model like for example
deterministic or stochastic approach
that you are going to use which type of
method that you that is suitable for
your fault for modeling or for network
based modeling then establishing a
simple model a model can be built
through mathematical formulation then
sensitivity analysis for validation
mathematical simulation may be highly
sensitive to parameter changes that
means in sensitivity analysis we change
certain parameters and see how it
affects the system and
whatever whatever is the effect in the
system that that needs to be validated
or cross checked with the experimental
data right so experimental tests and we
can uh use experimental tests of the
model prediction so we need some wet lab
validation sometimes or or probably if
you have a paper or literature already
been done
or experiments already been done you can
compare it can compare with that and see
whether your model is acting um as
as
real as possible or not right uh so then
the stating the agreements and
divergences between the experimental and
modeling uh whether the model results
agree with the experimental behavior if
results do not agree check the faults
check check for false assumptions right
over simplifications of the model wrong
model structure inadequate uh
experimental data or other inadequately
represented factors so all this will
check that whether uh what is the issue
with your model that is not giving or
it's not getting validated with the
experimental data iterative refinement
of the model refinement of model is also
very important because um the more you
refine the model the more you uh
fill up the gaps that are present in the
model the more accurate uh it gets right
or it gives you the answer the
perturbation of a uh to a network model
so perturbation means the changes that
we do to a model the networks of
different topologies uh
very uh vary in their resilience to
various types of uh various types of
perturbations the process starts with
systematic perturbation of biological
systems monitoring uh the pathway
responses
the integration of the data formulation
of mathematical models that describe the
structure of the system and its response
to perturbation so perturbation analysis
is very important where we for example
you knock out certain genes you knock
knock in certain genes or probably you
have uh you have just
stopped certain pathways in a metabolic
model or in a biochemical biochemical
network model and you see what changes
it goes
happens if there is no change that means
those pathways are not very important
for the for the for that particular for
that particular problem right so or uh
right so this this perturbation analysis
is very important even you can change
the concentrations you can change the
expression values of various genes and
proteins and see what happens to the
model how the model behaves right so
that is uh
that is a very regular thing that we do
in systems biology then applications of
biological network models are manifold
uh
right so you can use it in the whole
biology uh any any field of biological
sciences starting from uh starting from
uh
the
bio process technology or metabolic
engineering then in medical uh
biomedical sciences where you can use uh
our biomedical applications like uh
network-based drug discovery discovering
complex relate sorry personalized and
precision medicine right
so these can be done using aiml also but
uh this can be done using systems
biology approaches also so the choice is
yours um right
we do it in two ways it i always say
that
data
science in biology always gives rise to
two directions one is aiml based
approaches and another one is systems
biology based approaches so i'm talking
all about systems biology approaches
today like so plant and microbial
metabolic engineering personalized and
precision medicine network-based drug
discovery uh discovering complex
relations etc
now
network in france to us to understand
disease pathogenesis so this is the case
study or this is the um
you can say the research topic that we
are going to
uh
understand today this is one of the
applications that i have chosen because
i have worked a lot on
understanding disease pathogenesis uh
using network in friends all right uh so
systems uh biology and used to decipher
decipher uh
uh decipher uh these multicell
multiscaler uh
the pathogenesis of uh
the most of
the pathogenesis one second
this i cannot see the slide
the pathogenesis of most multi-genetic
diseases involves interactions and
feedback loops uh across multiple
temporal and spatial scales from
cellular to organism level so the
robust uh
characteristic of the network uh the
robust characteristic of the network uh
is uh traded off due to impact of
perturbations on the native network
leading to changes in the phenotypic
responses thereby exhibiting disease
states right uh next is clearly this
network inferences uh clearly the system
level uh
study uh is required to reveal the
fundamental principles of disease
initiation and progress
possible to understand the dynamics of
these networks using the disease model
so you can see here
the examples of disease pathogenesis
disease pathogenesis networks
so
the first example that i can give here
is a cancer network so a signaling
network of
a signaling network
of uh
remarkable complexity that is of
critical importance to cancer tumor so
this is the paper that has been
published so i have taken this picture
from that paper that is published in
2000 in cell
where they have shown the complexity of
the cancer cell network right so this is
not a network diagram actually this is
just a book diagram or you can say
literature based diagram uh right so
this is again a literature-based diagram
this is not a network diagram so you can
make a network out of this
out of this uh
from this
keeping this diagram as a as a base
based network then
next next example is that where you can
study disease pathogenesis network is
diabetes type 2 it has already been
published uh the diabetes type 2 model
it's a systems based or network based
model uh where you can see the various
biological these various nodes are
actually denotes the um you know the
biological processes protein abundance
cell secretion the various activities
actually uh not the genes and proteins
the various activities has been
represented with by by these various
nodes and edges
right
the nodes nodes but edges are
edges are actually here shows the either
it is increasing the activity or
decreasing the activity or directly
increasing the activity directly
increasing the activity directly
decreasing the activity so all these
connectivities uh can be explained so
this is basically understanding the
whole diabetic process uh or
type 2 diabetes uh model understanding
diabetes model so this is the
work that we have done in our lab
where
where we have made a
uh where we have worked on the network
inferences and also drug target
identifications using networks uh in
vitiligo or we call it as vitiligo uh
and autoimmune disorder it's a it's a
it's a chronic uh
it's an autoimmune disorder skin disease
when when the um the hyperactive
immune system kills its own
melanin
cells or melanocytes right uh
from the basal layer of the epidermis
epidermis which leads to patchy uh loss
of skin color right which is quite uh
quite
related to psoriasis and um also i we
have also done some work where uh we
have done the correlational networks
correlational networks between bt lego
and uh multiple sclerosis and uh
then um uh
rheumatoid arthritis and um limited
arthritis and psoriasis uh etc and also
we are working on connecting it to other
diseases like uh like uh
thyroid hyperthyroid hyperthyroidism and
then
and then um
diabetes etc so we are trying to do this
correlational network analysis between
uh between uh the because this type of
analysis gives you an idea that this
this type of complex diseases are not uh
not
caused by one factor they are
multifactorial diseases right
so we have developed along with that
also we have developed this uh
database which
has been published in two of the
journals um vitiligo uh information uh
resource uh vitiligo information
resource that is uh
we r v db we call it as very db here and
uh so so this is the whole structure or
features of the vrdb database uh where
we have differential genes interest
intersecting genes natural leads of lead
compounds so we have done some docking
studies also this is just for this
database we have done though this is not
our main area um so we have done some
network uh studies and we have shown
them in the network gallery uh where we
have shown differential g networks
intersection networks with multi
multiple sclerosis intersection networks
with psoriasis uh intersection network
with rheumatoid arthritis dark uh target
protein uh networks and also uh we have
done some
lego information resource profiles like
kdb connectivity pdb dv connectivity
string db connectivity etc right so we
have used mostly uh microarray data here
uh for the gene network and
to
we have analyzed those microarray data
and uh
done this uh analysis and done this
network studies
we are still working a lot on different
aspects of uh vitiligo information
resource it has more other informations
i would like all of you to visit that
website this is called as
www.vtligoin4s.com
so you can get uh to know our database
more and we have more uh such uh network
based analysis and also some some sort
of drug target identification analysis
and we have published them in prg and uh
uh and f thousand research uh recently
so these are some of the features
uh like uh ppi networks ggi networks
like gene gene interaction networks
protocol interaction networks etc now uh
we have come almost to the end of the
uh
almost to the end of this talk that what
is the take home message that we can do
from here uh that in recent years
systems biology approaches and more
specifically
network-based approaches emerged as
powerful tools for studying complex
diseases
these approaches are often built
are often built on the knowledge of
physical uh or functional interactions
between molecules which are usually
represented as an interaction network a
variety of intermolecular interactions
including protein protein interactions
protein dna interactions and rna
interactions are essential to these
cooperative uh activities these
interactions can be conveniently
represented as
uh networks with nodes with the networks
that is graphs with nodes and which
denote molecules or the components and
the links which denote the interactions
between them network biology provides a
powerful tool it is a part of systems
biology but it it provides a powerful
tool for this study or an elegant way of
studying the complex diseases or complex
problems since uh in biological sciences
or biomedical sciences network based
approaches leverage the idea that
complex diseases can be better
understood uh from the perspective of
dysregulated molecules than at the
individual
gene level so
uh i guess
i'm
almost uh
at the end of uh my talk
uh now
just uh one slide that shows my group my
research group uh at emmett university
noida um in india and we have this
website if anybody is interested you can
visit this website and see our different
researches and different papers and book
chapters and various aspects and various
projects we are already running uh a dbt
funded project
we have people
from here uh
who has got dst sub young scientist
awards welcome trust genome campus they
have uh they have been uh like no uh got
fellowships for uh attending various
workshops at welcome trust uh genome
campus in the mbl ebi even i have also
gone there for uh training and because
mine as my model was accepted by buyer
models in embl ebi campus so i was
selected there so ongoing funded project
we have ai base we also work on ai nml
uh based approaches also for various uh
omics or for various big data in biology
for analyzing them uh all right
so what we do we do genome scale model
reconstructions we do constraint based
modeling flux analysis clinical data
analytics and association studies
discovering biomarkers and generating
machine learning models that we do uh
separately that is basically being
headed by dr priyanka narada she is also
uh the another
coin
investigator in our lab and along with
me
she is also the mentor here
multi multi omics integration with
genome scale metabolic model so this is
this is purely systems biology
multi-level biological network modeling
and analysis so these are our
project associates uh phd scholars and
research associates etc so thank you all
uh for
listening to me
and i could uh i hopefully i could
cover
uh
as much as i could
in systems biology and network
inferences and how network biology can
be used in solving various biological
problems
thank you so much
thank you
thank you very much sir
it was amazing to
get to know so much up from you the talk
was really insightful and
we explored a lot of applications about
systems biology and network analysis
well we have a few questions in the chat
from our audience so i will take up some
of them
um
this question is from aushmita and she
asks can the system's biology approach
be used to understand the immune system
of an organism and are the similar
databases used in the process like the
ones used for drug discovery
yes definitely uh presently we are
working on similarly as exactly for
vitiligo so since vitiligo is a
autoimmune disorder uh we have not
worked on the immunological networks we
can work on immunological and this is
quite new uh for making immunological
networks rather than going into gene
regulatory networks or uh protein
networks we can we can specifically
focus on immunological networks uh for
and mostly for immunological networks we
use uh mathematical modeling or
differential equation based uh modeling
approaches uh uh insist from systems
biology for model to model them and
the databases that we use for drug
discovery are different from the
databases we use in systems biology we
can yes definitely
take the if you are going for drug
target interaction or drug target
interaction networks then definitely you
need to use those drug-based drug
databases uh or probably uh
the various uh databases that we use for
uh for uh getting the drug molecules and
do some
do some
initial level docking studies to uh to
just cross check them right uh so
those things can be
done at that level but uh definitely not
for pure systems biology we don't use
drug discovery based databases that are
specifically for drug discovery
okay thank you so much dr saint gupta
here's one more question from sanju
vikashini and
the question is what are the
applications of system strategy in
industries we
learned about the research application
but what
like what are the sectors in which the
industries might benefit from systems
biology oh okay so uh in industry first
of all the industry that i will tell uh
is
is uh this um
uh the the antibiotic based industry or
uh the uh various uh secondary
metabolites or uh various uh plant-based
metabolites based based industry where
we do
where we
actually optimize the production of
various metabolites
from
from smaller organisms because those
organisms from where we get good
metabolites are probably the secondary
metabolites uh are are very minuscule so
uh we use uh model organisms like e coli
or saccharomyces celibacy to to optimize
their production and that can be done
and that can be taken to the industry
for example you must have heard about
uh
the companies like genometica in uh in
us or uh
like so those those companies uh those
companies uh use uh
use systems biology and synthetic
biology approaches for uh for higher
production of uh various useful bio
products like those are produced in the
cell factory right
so this is one of the application and
another application in uh health and
diseases identification of drug targets
identification of biomarkers
uh it helps in drug discovery like no
drug in drug discovery we used to uh
take one molecule two molecules three
molecules at a time but now using this
uh systems biology approaches we can i
we can work with multiple number of drug
targets at a time so that is that
actually uh aggravates the or uh the
importance or significance of or the
more productivity of um research in drug
designing right or
drug discovery
so these are some some there are many
other uh we can make models which
we can make various models which can be
used by the various uh healthcare
sectors or experimentalists to
validate their data so those models can
also be used as uh as uh
as a as a as a uh model system right
because there are various ethical issues
by for using human for example human gem
right as i have mentioned genome scale
model in human so you cannot use human
for uh for human samples for every uh
experiments uh there are various ethical
issues related to it so instead of that
if you can use the human uh genome scale
model or whole human genome skill model
like whole human genome you can use
whole human genome skill metabolic model
uh for for for various studies for
example if you wanted to study study a
particular type of cancer you can take
the whole genome scale model of human
and study that particular aspect of
cancer
in
in using that those models those systems
there are many other applications i have
mentioned few of them
right thank you so much dr sengupta and
in continuation to the answer that you
already gave right now there's another
question so john wants to know that can
we apply systems biology in organ on a
chip model so that's again a substitute
for testing anything on a live organism
yes yes organ on a cheap model but uh we
use spatial based modeling so uh i have
never worked on that but yes definitely
uh we can use uh
see there is a project called as uh
physio human physium project that is
being that is an ongoing project where
they generate these virtual organ models
organ models they generate
musculoskeletal models they generate
pancreatic models they have they have
generated this uh big heart models then
pancreas so all those models can be
generated
computationally but then they have to
take it to the organ on a chip
they can translate it to the organ
ownership
system
all right thank you so much doctor saint
gupta and here's the final question from
my end so i had this question in my mind
you talked about various modeling and
simulation tools what's the
computational power required to run
those softwares
it does not require very high and
systems you can use it in your simple
laptop also the only problem is with the
data suppose that i think you are also
aware of if you are using
rnsec data or probably if you are using
ngs the whole genome sequence data then
definitely you need uh
the more computational uh power like for
your system for processing those data
then we can enter into comp uh systems
biology that does not require much
computational uh power but yes for like
matlab based uh which is actually a uh
paid software matlab and uh it's a heavy
software uh for that probably you may
need little bit better systems but
otherwise even even a even in a simple
laptop you can make models
but yes
for the initial data processing you need
uh
computational space and power
right i get it well thank you so much dr
sengupta it was a pleasure to have you
as a guest today and we learned about so
many things i'm sure the audience got
many messages to take home from today's
webinar it was insightful for all of us
thank you so much for your time
thank you thank you
mr barua
all right thank you so much everyone for
joining in and before we wrap up today's
great webinar i have a few things to
share with you which
might you might be interested in some of
the more opportunities coming up and
some other ways in which you can benefit
your
thoughts for learning
so adding on to
data science and
programs on data science we as i
mentioned in the beginning at omixlogic
we also have some modules and training
in collaboration with very many of
universities and organizations
where we talk about
uh the data science concept and how we
can apply it into bioinformatics so i
will quickly walk you through the
various programs and training
opportunities that we have at tommy's
logic find biotech and all of these
learning training modules are held
synchronously as well as asynchronously
that is live as well as pre-recorded it
is live through interactive zoom
sessions there are various self-guided
study materials already uploaded on our
learn omix logitech platform as well as
practical hands-on assignments on the
tbi info platform and the amix logic
code playground which i will be touching
upon really shortly
this is a snippet of the
way in which we have integrated the
coding console onto our platform where
you don't need to download any extra ide
or a software to run
codes like python or r which you can
directly do it right over here and
generate various meaningful biological
results
now how to do that has been
comprehensively mentioned in the various
courses where we have
courses like genomics python for
bioinformatics are for
informatics and more these courses
introduce you to the concepts of data
science in biological sciences
biomachine learning course introduces
the logic behind machine learning what
are the various types of machine
learning tools and algorithms that can
be used
including
a tutorial on how to use excel python r
studio as well as the t bio info
platform
you can also go beyond these resources
and write your own codes in a much more
limitless way using
jupyter notebook or google collab and
github
through these programs we help students
understand the concepts behind
unsupervised machine learning various
clustering methods supervised machine
learning feature selection
and regression models deep learning
and network analysis and also combining
various strategies
for machine learning
in general
we also
have a special design of delivering
training programs which includes
hands-on aspect as well as project-based
learning
learning only makes sense when you are
able to apply it in a practical way and
therefore
omix logic trainings are different than
others because it incorporates various
projects examples which are taken from
published research papers which are
publicly available their public data
sets and
goes through a tutorial which is
designed in such a way that you will
walk the steps in which a scientist or a
researcher did or perform their own
analysis in this way you will get a
sense of how to define a research
question what are the various methods
and techniques to apply to generate
meaningful results and finally how to
draw a biologically significant
conclusion from the
results that you have generated from
these
tools
now i will quickly go over the t by info
platform because as we all know
biologists are not very good coders i
mean that's kind of a usual
understanding well many people are
expert in coding nowadays
so
if you are not an expert in coding that
doesn't mean the end of the world
because at find biotech economics logic
we have a comprehensive point-and-click
ai enabled cloud-based platform where
you don't need to write even a single
line of code and what you can basically
do is just with a click of one pointer
you can get your entire analysis done so
this is how the tbi info platform looks
like and just by clicking and joining
the various tools
which are mentioned here from the
various boxes you create a pipeline
through which you can generate results
from your high throughput data sets and
then take it forward to analyze the
tibia info platform also generates
publication worthy graphics and images
and figures which you can
incorporate into your
research paper publication or any
posters
the t by info serves various purposes
which includes the sequencing rna seq
domain about various machine learning
tools such as unsupervised supervised
and more and variant calling structure
analysis phylogenetics and a lot more
than that
so here's again talking about how these
omnis logic courses not only teaches you
to understand the logic behind
bioinformatics but also teaches you to
be to get
expertized with python and r
so these are some of the courses that we
already have in our on our platform
which you can complete at your own pace
whenever you want
so
python are and
finally you can
you can translate your understanding and
your knowledge to basic and
translational research projects that you
can do
so the entire story winds up
like this at omix logic you get training
you learn some concepts you learn some
skills then you apply it in your own
project and
you can be
someone who can benefit from our ongoing
research fellowship program which is
equivalent to the internship programs
that you have all across the world
by completing the fellowship program you
will be able to design your own research
project with the help of mental guidance
at find biotech so here's an example of
a project completed by a student from
amt university noida
her name is vedika rai and she
did her project in the transcriptomics
of kovit 19 which is now published on
our platform
as dr sengupta also mentioned we have a
huge collaboration between find biotech
and amity university and as a result of
this collaboration especially with them
at university noida campus we bring
various exciting opportunities for the
students of empty university such as
industry academic internships and more
so
apart from the already uploaded
asynchronous courses that we have on the
device on the omnix logic learn platform
we also have various programs which are
launched time to time in these programs
you will get
training from our mentors who will
give you their insights into some
specialistic aspect of various
applications of bioinformatics for
example right now we are running a
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
program where you will learn about how
you can apply bioinformatics for
research in the field of
infectious diseases specifically taking
the examples of covid19 ebola malaria
and tuberculosis
in the future we will also be having
specialized courses on precision
oncology where we will be talking about
cancer research in more depth
for anybody who is looking to start with
a journey in bioinformatics you are most
welcome to check out our introduction to
bioinformatics program which introduces
you to the various concepts of
bioinformatics
we also have programs dedicated to
genomics and genomics in the virtual lab
we also will be having specialized
programs on transcriptomics and data
science for
biomedical data analysis such as the one
that in which we will be talking about
all the concepts that we were discussing
today
we also have a major collaboration with
the federation of asian biotechnology
association or faba and as a result of
this collaboration we will be coming up
with various exciting opportunities for
the students in india and asia as a
result of the
huge network of industries that faba is
associated with
talking about our international
collaborations we also have a massive
collaboration with the louisiana's
biomedical research network and
louisiana state university
where we are providing courses and
training programs for the students who
are a part of this institution
talking about the national association
of idea principles investigators
also known as nepi we are providing free
bioinformatics education to 23 states in
the united states of america and puerto
rico and as a result of this
major collaboration many students in the
united states of america are benefiting
in the domain of mathematics education
research and training
so
it's a good opportunity for requesting
all of you to get stay in touch with us
we are available on all the social media
handles please find us and stay in touch
with us to get notified about any
upcoming opportunity where you can take
part and benefit from
a quick reminder about psionic so we
were having various topics throughout
the very many months and in february we
had bioinformatics and data science we
will be having many more sessions coming
up in the next weeks
and in march
specifically on 31st march and first
april we will be having a huge
international conference which is known
as the omix research symposium this is a
great opportunity for all of you to take
part in in this
symposium we will be having
special guest
speakers from all around the world from
various academic partners from various
universities from various industries and
also research labs who will be sharing
their research and progresses made all
throughout the past year and the
applications in bioinformatics
leveraging it for
performing cutting-edge research we will
be also having various exciting
opportunities for students namely the
post representation competition where
you will be given the opportunity to
submit your own research as an as a
poster these posters will be evaluated
by our judges and you will be getting
prizes at the end of the poster
presentation competition
more information about the symposium the
poster conference and the panel of
speakers and the dates and times will be
available on our social media handles as
well as on your email so keep an eye on
all of those channels and platforms
finally it's a request to all of you
present here to kindly scan or
copy the link and give us a feedback of
how your experience was in this
particular webinar your feedback is
important for us because it helps us
provide you quality
learning experience in a very smooth and
seamless way
so here's a heads up for all of you in
coming up then in the next psionics
session we will be having dr erska as
our guest speaker she is an assistant
director at the louisiana state
university chevape and she will be
talking about bioinformatics and data
science training and how she and her
group is revolutionizing the way in
which bioinformatics is provided to the
students and how students from any
background can learn and apply
bioinformatics in their research so this
webinar will be held on february 11 2022
at 3 p.m central standard time
and on february 18th we will be having
dr mohit mazum who is a business
development director and project mentor
at find biotech and he will be talking
about structural biology
this research aspect as well as how you
should design your research project and
your abstract this is in lieu with the
poster presentation competition so i
encourage all of you to take part in it
and attend these sessions so that you
can get the insights from our experts
about what's the best way to design your
abstract what's the best way to design
your project and that would help you be
in a better position to
be awarded the winner of this poster
presentation competition
having said that we are now at the end
of today's
um webinar session i will take up all
the questions that you have in the chat
feel free to use the chat section to
post more questions i will be
definitely answering all of you so about
the recording of today's session you
will be definitely getting the recording
through your emails please keep an eye
on that
and also on our social media handles we
will be posting the links to the
recordings
talking about the
training in africa and nigeria we do
have various training programs that are
running in africa we have our team of
our mix logic
at africa who are based in african who
are providing quality training and
education so
if you're interested in learning more
about those trainings and how to connect
to the group please send an email to us
at marketing at the ratebind.bio
i will put it in the chat
or you can also send it to
communications at the red finder bio
and we will provide you with further
information regarding
the training in
nigeria i will share the
link of the feedback form
with you so that you can
go over with it just give me a moment
um okay so the whatsapp group was full i
will check it and i will send you for
the links
regarding the
whatsapp links and i will tell you about
the poster presentation session in just
a minute just give me one moment i will
share my screen and
i will show you what the poster
presentation
session looks like
so
while i am doing that the poster
presentation session basically is
for students who are doing your own
research or you want to do a research
you are welcome to submit your abstracts
for now and once you share
our submitter abstracts the deadline is
28th of february
once you submit your abstract with us we
will be doing a
screening of those abstracts to identify
the best ones
and once we have identified them we will
definitely
contact you regarding the guidelines for
sharing your poster
and
i am resharing my screen to enable you
the poster presentations
link
so this is the page for poster
presentation i am also putting it down
in the chat so that you can also visit
it
so
the poster presentation
for the mixed logic research symposium
covers these following topics
omix and bioinformatics
obviously applied in research
you might have done it as an independent
project or a project with your
university professors or your summer
internship somewhere you are welcome to
submit such projects
if it is in the domain of ai and machine
learning and data science that is the
application of data science ai l into
bioinformatics and biological science
we are also interested in welcoming
abstracts in the domain of astrobiology
and space omits that is a new and
exciting domain because we will be
having a separate panel in the symposium
dedicated to astrobiology and space
comics and
various great speakers from
from the most famous organizations in
space sciences and astrobiology will be
coming
in this symposium so it's a great
opportunity to
give exposure to your research and
interest in front of those experts and
finally if your research is in the
domain of computational biology and
biotech and pharma you're also welcome
to submit your
abstracts here
now here's a quick guideline for the
abstracts
so the abstract length can be from 150
to 200 words you can you should divide
it into various segments such as
objective methods results and conclusion
the font should be in monsterat and 12
points and it must be a pdf file so you
have to convert it into a pdf file and
submit it using this particular form
right here just go down you will get an
option to choose your file and submit
your
abstract here the deadline is 28
february so keep that in mind
here are the three prizes that you are
that you can win the best poster
presentation the best citizen science
project and young sheldon i work for
high school students who are doing
cutting-edge research
in the domain of bioinformatics
so that's all that i have to share about
the poster presentation
if you guys have any further question
please feel free to put that down in the
chat section and i am happy to take it
up
if not then that brings us to the end of
today's ionic session i had a great
experience talking and interacting with
all of you
we definitely learned a lot and got
some great insights into systems biology
and network analysis from dr gupta
thanks thanks to dr
once again for his time
and
if you want to contact us
uh anytime later on please feel free to
send me an email in the email ids that i
have shared in the chat marketing and
communications and the reminder bio and
i will be happy to answer all your
questions
having said that that brings us to the
end of today's ionic session we will
again meet on february 11 at 3 pm cst
until then
take care thank you so much for joining
us
and
i wish you a very good evening see you
soon
yeah buddy i will send a
link to
[Music]
whatsapp by email when i share the
recording of the session so you can use
that to join us
you